president biden has warned that extreme
supporters of donald trump are a threat
to democracy
in a prime time speech in pennsylvania
the u.s president said the make america
great again agenda is determined to take
the country backwards
donald trump and the migrant republicans
represented extremism
that threatens the very foundations of
our republic the republican party today
is dominated driven and intimidated
by donald trump and the migrant
republicans
and that is a threat to this country
well we can now speak to former
republican congressman joe walsh and joe
it's great to have you here with us um
this evening just listening to biden's
speech that is this attempt of course to
make that distinction between um decent
republicans if you like and the others
how has the republican party changed in
your political lifetime we've gone from
the era of reagan to trump
uh it's good to be with you and i i was
i've been a republican my whole life up
until two years ago because
the problem now is the republican party
is fully radicalized what used to be
fringe or crazy in the republican party
now is the republican party um and and i
come from that world i come from mega
world and what joe biden said last night
about mega world is accurate
the world needs to understand that one
of america's two political parties
is fully anti-democracy they really are
and so i thought it was very important
for president biden to stand up
and call out that threat
and so what do you um feel somebody like
yourself and obviously describing the
history that you've had with the
republican party and of course the the
detachment that you now feel do you feel
that there's a home for you in a
republican party as it is today
could there could you see yourself
actually having a home there now
no i don't have a home and i don't
believe i'll ever be back in the
republican party and people like liz
cheney uh from wyoming who lost a couple
weeks ago she doesn't have a home in the
republican party
this republican party is what it is
and it is a party now that denies basic
truths
they no longer believe in democracy
and they embrace an authoritarianism
i don't think the party's going to
change for a long long time if they ever
do
i think what will happen in america is
they'll be the birth of a new maybe a
third major political party so do you
think then that the era of trump has
taken over the party
oh most certainly
and it's not over and here's the scary
truth
if donald trump announces next week that
he's running for president
he will get the republican party
nomination and it won't be close and
nobody will challenge him
this party is still his he could be
indicted
uh i would dare say he could be in jail
and he'd probably still get the
republican party nomination
the party is in his grasp and what he
has radicalized
um even if he were to leave tomorrow
it's still
the part the party will still continue
down his road so what you're saying is
there is absolutely nothing that donald
trump can do to derail him to lose that
strong
hardcore fan base that he has what
you're effectively saying is he can do
whatever he wants and he'll still get
their vote and support
think about this
uh on january 6 2021
donald trump led an insurrection
he led a violent attempt to overthrow an
american election he did that and still
the republican party stayed with him and
still
he owns the party even after he did that
so
no i don't think there's anything he can
do
that will will change that
well let's look at what um republicans
like yourself are doing or perhaps
former republicans who obviously want to
see a change in the party what is it
that is being done then behind the
scenes to kind of work against that sort
of era of trump and that grasp that he
has on the republican party
we're in a funny place in america i
think most people like me who are former
republicans and they consider themselves
to be conservatives
right now
they believe like i believe that the
republican party is a direct threat to
our democracy
we only have two parties in america so
most people like me right now are either
joining the democratic party or helping
democrats win and look
i i it's not easy because i am a
conservative
but right now we're at this weird place
in america where it's all about saving
democracy so we all kind of have to help
the democratic party now
and so i'm really keen then to know
where you are at the moment because at
the moment you sound like you have no
home politically you're politically
homeless at the moment or
are you where are you sitting at the
moment
i'm sitting at a chair in washington dc
you know i used to
i used to be a congressman and i
represented a district in illinois
but because i turned against trump the
people in that district
basically kicked me out of the district
i had no home there so in a weird way i
am homeless i'm in washington d.c right
now doing all i can
to try to help wake up the rest of the
country to the threat that my former
republican party is that's what i'm
focused on right now
jerry it's good to get your thoughts
that's jay walsher he's a former
republican congressman thank you